all right let's move on 31 pending
challenges uh this time I guess I'll
play someone random them give me a
random number between 1 and 31 that's
the number I can count to 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
Macha or is it ma qua whatever your name
is good luck
I'll play you for I think every game so
far has been an e4 opening with the
exception of the very first game against
Patrick JMT ok so now we have completely
different opening Scandinavian I can't
play the Halloween gambit just have to
play chess Queen D AIT's actually ran
into this in a tournament game recently
I'll have to remember the preparation
Knight f3 no Bishop g4 will come at some
point
really trying to remember the
preparation h3
I think h3 yeah he's hacking b7 it's
still prep I played this in Australia
huh
and my opponent blitzed out literally
the whole game and he equalized and then
we drew but then he showed me what to do
I think there's a clever move here
Bishop f4 so he was showing me after the
game how white secures some advantage I
don't know like I'm trying to rely on
memory but also just trying to like
figure out the position I'm pretty sure
Bishop f4 where I socked the pawn but
does it work Bishop f4 idea was
where's the Bishop d3 first that was
Bishop f4
yeah let's play [ __ ] before if he's
brave enough to take on d4 I'll figure
things out but I think the eventual
ideas a Castle queenside and then go for
a son like g4 g5
this is a type of opening I should I
should know better I shouldn't be
thinking so early like when I
encountered it in the tournament I was
spending like five minutes every move
trying to figure figure things out from
the very beginning that's not what you
want to do in the opening Wow Queen
takes d4 so he's accepting the gambit so
I know there is some idea with Knight b5
I don't know if it works in this
position though like Knight B 5
it's almost winning pawn takes b5 Queen
takes b7 the problem here is that
there's Queenie forecheck we have to
trade Queens but then the line keeps
going because I had Bishop takes b5
check King d8 and then castling
queenside I guess he has a 96 there so
Knight d5 takes takes Queenie for Erik
wait no 95 takes takes I guess the
question is do I take on me 7 and B 5
first let's imagine Knight d5 takes and
I take on me 5 with check first
because if knight c6 I win if Knight
beany 7 and I have ripped e8 but then he
has Queen before Chuck so 97 I take on
b7 24 takes takes castling queenside
rook ta then I have Bishop c7 but again
he has
I don't know might be five ticks ticks
97 thinking just Bishop d3 is a move to
maybe five takes Queen takes Queen e4 I
take take wait a minute
all right no it's mean like Bishop c6
and then work that they've broken the
night five takes Queen takes Queen e4 I
take he takes takes King d8 promise 96
saves them in so many lines
so let's play Bishop d3 I stocked up on
Bishop d3 maybe should have played
quicker I spent so much time on night b5
because if it works it might just be
winning but I didn't see it the threat
maybe is now Knight b5 I I remember when
I played the game I could have got this
position now I think nike5 I was
actually winning I think we actually
transposed into what could have happened
in my my tournament game because now he
doesn't have Queenie forecheck like
Knight d5 unfriending c7 and the Queen
he has to take I take on b7 I'm almost
winning the rook he only has Queen d5
and then I just take and defy with check
but then he wasn't like g7 it might be
b7 I have bishop c6 if Knight f d7 queen
CH should be good enough I'm pretty sure
this is working I'm wondering if he's
watching his I mean d6 is a type of
movie should be aware of Knight d5 maybe
I don't know maybe carelessness sir
on your estimating the play I'll have to
check the the actual theory and I know
my game is on
chesty B so I'm like after this game
I'll go to chef Stevie I'll download the
I'll bring it in to me chess and then
I'll see how it compares as I was
actually thinking about doing like after
I had played the game I was thinking
about just doing a youtube video
covering how to get an advantage against
the Queen d8 Scandinavian in this
variation is like how I would make good
YouTube content especially because John
Bartholomew recommends this line for
black but then I don't know I was too
difficult with the tournament it's
playing game every day and then I got
sick so Eve
this will be that video yeah there's not
too many options for black I'm not sure
what he's thinking about maybe he's just
realizing his doom is what other
candidate moves Bishop before check that
I have c3 I'll happened then he takes
the knight Oh interesting
yeah maybe this wasn't so clear so King
f1
I forgot the bishop is hanging here too
I decide with half Queen C a check and
some lines this is a little bit unclear
actually I forgot about blacks resources
I think I should play c3 and then Mike
Bishop is less dependent on d3 so c3 he
takes I take King somewhere I do I play
King f1 much safer move King f1 takes
Queen takes Queen takes off for Queen C
aids chess is so complicated there
should be for a very good move though
maybe I could just Castle queenside that
would be nifty see three takes in Castle
queenside threatening to win the Queen
but he gets Queen c5 then I take on b7
let's do it this is I have to play c3
first this is a no increment game I may
have just like massively confused myself
I might just be like losing here but
okay I'm going for this line because now
I'm actually forking you can't really
take on c3 because when I just check and
win the Queen meanwhile if you play as
Queen c5 i I guess I have to take on b7
and hope for the best
Oh actually Queen c5
I can play Bishop d6 so he takes I took
here and win the Queen how much material
have I sacked I've stocked a piece so
far so Queen here here he takes Bishop
takes b5 in 97 I win the Queen then he
temporarily has a rook in two pieces for
the Queen but I keep in the [ __ ] that
I'll have rook d1 and Queen takes b7
I'm very interested to analyze this game
afterwards it's very complex between c5
okay so Bishop d6 if Queen takes b7 and
he could just Castle I mean it's also
option though actually Queen Jegs b7
Castle me I take the rook I'm up
material it takes on c3 I take he's
attacking
there's no time let's go for this
spicy play how many pawns on mine down
down one pawn and a piece temporarily
I'm thinking there's some lines where I
things can simplify a little bit but
most lines I should keep some
conversation and I do have to move
quicker
he's probably debating between taking
and moving the Queen somewhere if he
moves the Queen somewhere I take I have
the bishop hair and b5 should be weak
and he wouldn't be able to castle still
okay so we're going into the slime
guaranteed to win the Queen and the
bishop is still hanging - so yeah this
is what I was looking at earlier where I
have rook t1 and Queen takes b7 and I
was thinking I mean okay locks still up
material but there's a lot of pressure
if King e7 maybe I could take if Knight
takes I of queen d3
if King takes my queen takes b7
ok so keen e7 is losing maybe I
shouldn't tell him the losing moves
maybe King e7 isn't losing well so he
needs to defend the bishop so I guess
the bishop has to move and then I take
on b7 and then this and this are
target's actually there's some funny
line like a vision e5 I can I was
thinking I could take twice on g7 and
take on b7 but then there's Bishop c7
but okay this looks very fun for whites
I should see 5 well now that line could
actually work like just take twice on g7
don't see anything wrong with it take on
b7
and now I finally what material oh no
wait
die blunder I forgot about King g6 so I
take on b7 first wait rook takes takes
takes king g6 before oh that doesn't
work so I have to take care first good
thing I fixed the pre move in time now I
can take on g7 and check and win the
bishop it's still gonna be a fight
good news is I have Queen and only one
pawn for the two rooks those rocks
aren't too coordinated a7 could be weak
thinking in this position that's good
I don't think there's much to think
about you have to allow Quincy a check
after roof takes you seven queen CA r of
t it i can decide between queen c 6
check first and taking the bishop i'll
probably take the bishop first cuz i
attack the pond
the pawns attacked if I wasn't upon I
have three connected passers and black
can't castle ever d7 I probably check
and play Queen b7 and then pick up the
pond
what were my grades in school
I forget the school was such a long time
ago I did enough to get by okay I'll win
the pond just have to manage time
and the king is still exposed so I can
try and use it to further my agenda but
the rooks will be coordinating very soon
so let's start pushing pawns mmm
wants to win f2 let's defend from a
distance
my king Carly belongs on a 2 and my pawn
belongs at the end of the board
yeah so I was looking at this line where
you want to have King a 2 and that's the
nice thing about having extra pawns like
he can't trade off the two rooks for the
Queen so that's just a winning King pawn
ending and my Queen keeps okay the two
pawns defended and now my a pawn will
start running
I don't care about left to anymore
and the Queen is preventing rip da was
preventing ripped yet now queen bee it's
the threats
okay the time is good enough and he
resigns okay weird game was some sharp
stuff first thing was first let me find
this game that I was referring to it's
playing a strong I am from Australia so
it's good to chesty be anyone who wants
to look at my over the board tournament
games the site has a pretty extensive
database the game was against already
Dale we drew in 16 moves like he blitzed
out the first 16 moves it was ridiculous
yeah I'd like 7 extra minutes at the end
of the game
oh my opponent says the Bishop f4 lion
is something I've only seen once or
twice well maybe you'll start seeing it
more if people watch this the stream I
don't know if I miss played it as it
looked
complicated I'll make a new study clean
d8 scan D secret preparation okay and
then I'll start by importing the game I
played in the tournament
this was Rosendale December 2018 and
then the other game just played just
copy the link me chess is great if you
have a study and you want to add a game
that you play it on me chess into the
study just add a new chapter and then
just paste the URL and then it imports
the game
so how did my game go well I played h3
immediately oh I played Bishop III ah so
this was a was this one moment in the
game where he said I think he said at
this point I should play Bishop f4 and
that's what I did and that's what I did
in this game so the same exact line I
remember distinctly because we went over
the game briefly afterwards and he said
95 was just winning well I guess I
wasn't able to figure it out because I
was I spent so much time here much time
that I spend seven minutes of people
maybe can't see no people can't see okay
so I had eight minutes I spent almost
three whole minutes on dish of d3 does
this line it's so close to winning Queen
e4 check I have to take this might be
the type of variation where you need
like more extensive computer preparation
yeah one of the lines I was thinking of
as if 97 Bishop c64 King blacks pieces
so if King d8 I didn't want to go into
this because it's 96 blocks the D file
and lights down a piece so Bishop e5
check was the other option but then 97 I
don't know I'm gonna be slightly lazy
and just get an immediate answer from
the engine cuz engine knows best not
suggesting that b5 but giving white some
nice compensation like if one side is
down upon an engine is still favoring
that side then there's usually a lot of
compensation Bishop d3 playable ok
Knight b5 ooh
so the engine was interesting the engine
didn't seem like b5 right away only when
we play it it says plus 0.5 and when you
play Knight d5 it says plus 0.9 probably
because the engine isn't using so much
CPU power CPU settings
what I thought used to B's like CPU miss
you control the lines but I really
thought you can control the CPU usage oh
you can make it go deeper
ah so the green bar means it's so
calculating maybe and then if you click
this I think it increases a death yeah
so it takes time I don't want to kill my
computer though because the combination
of streaming and stockfish it could be
causing too much overheating Oh CPU
usage option is only available in
certain browsers okay so it used to be
available on chrome back when I use
Chrome but chrome ironically took up too
much CPU usage so let's figure out why
is it giving an advantage for whites
Bishop takes b5 okay 90 d7 Queen Jake's
b7 or two units ah there's a b7 you only
move clink whinny for Chuck takes takes
castles so it's very a deep analysis Cal
saying 96 I see with 96 ah rook takes d6
what a move
rook takes c6 and then working one nasty
Bishop here and then Bishop takes you
six
everything's pinned and whites down the
rook but winning the bishop and then
winning more stuff what a move okay so
this is useful to know if I were to like
make a repertoire on this line I would
have this in a separate chapter you will
see people can't see the chapters tab
but if I wanted to just make a new
chapter say like Queen d8 operation and
then just save this line as its own
chapter
and ensure I could like add to it and
review it so 9c3 here here here
so I guess h3 is chemo Bishop f4 I
remember after the game he was telling
me he wouldn't take but he would play I
think like e6000 probably six there
should be masters games yeah castling
John Bartholomew beats a pheromone and
did that happen
whoa so so thir Manu Bishop at 4:00
seems like black just equalized if I'm
sliding this really seriously I look at
like the GM Games and then find
deviations like how to improve on their
play usually with the help of engine so
this seems like mainline it should be
for John Bartholomew is probably the
world one of the world's leading experts
on this variation so knowing his
preparation and then using the engine to
try and refute it it's probably the best
approach a three there's not too many
games here anyway if people want to
explore this the study is free or
completely public on me chess and if
anyone wants to have a study that they
control with this preparation you can
you can go this button and then clone
and then that will give you a duplicate
of the study and then give you ownership
so I know people want to play games
well hopefully that was instructed maybe
I'll make like a whole youtube snippets
video out of that just devoted to Queen
ji it's candy so for the YouTube
audience hope you guys enjoyed that and
I'll see you guys in the future or
you'll see me in the future